even in death Kenya's second president
Daniel arap moy remains a deeply
polarizing figure the man who led the
country for 24 years has divided opinion
on how canyons remember him thousands
attended his funeral service in Nairobi
and those who stood to speak led by
heads of state from Kenya and
neighboring countries called him a
statesman a nationalist and pan-african
a man of integrity and selflessness the
country and its commitment to uniting
Kenyans informed his eye of philosophy
of peace love and unity which became the
rallying call for our nation it's
exactly what I wore when I was in Kuwait
um where I remembers him differently we
were treated worse than convicted
criminals he reads to us an excerpt from
his book I refuse to die I was to be
punished which documents his life under
Moyes rule he remembers the detention
torture and how he was hounded even
after his release and forced into exile
thousands of the former president's
political opponents were detained after
an attempted coup in 1982 and during the
clamor for democracy in the 1990s there
is nothing more harrowing than total
isolation it broke people and it breaks
people in fact I know people who could
not deal with isolation how they got
strokes some just went crazy so that was
my kind of detention
Moyes body lain stayed for three days
government officials see more than
200,000 people came to see him Sam told
us it was out of curiosity because as
president he was unreachable as much as
he seemed to be everywhere many of those
who lived to Morris time in office say
he was larger than life his presence was
felt everywhere his face was on the
currency streets building than even a
national holiday was named after him
TV bulletins always started with his
news and his wife was low some people
also accuse him and his colleagues of
plundering the economy allowing tribal
violence to persist and nearly
destroying the country but many who came
to this stadium named after him said no
matter his mistakes he was a symbol of
peace and unity Catherine soy al-jazeera
nairobi kenya